is it true that you saw Ryan Gosling in  a juice bar I was beyond a dork because  I didn't recognize him he was beefed up  because I think he had just done Drive  which is the best movie and he was  staring at me and smiling and what did  he say what did he talk he didn't say  anything he just smiled at me and then I  was the idiot and I did that thing that  people do to celebrities where they're  like I know you we've worked together we  must have worked together and I was like  you just I know like we've I know you  and he was like smiling just like he had  like a secret and he was just like you  don't know me and then  um and then I said what's your name and  he said Ryan and I said I know we know  each other Ryan and he was like we don't  and then he left and the minute he left  I was like Ryan Gosling Ryan Gosling  Gosling Gosling Gosling like and then it  was over must have been I mean literally  10 years ago